Should YOU trust ME?
If you're intelligent enough, you can probably
figure it out.
[[MUSIC PLAYING]]
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
Here's something you might not think about
everyday: TRUST.
Trust is a vital part of life and relationships.
I mean, if you're unwilling to trust anyone
or anything, it would be a cynical, sad life
indeed.
A few years ago, the Pew Research Center found
that, worldwide, societies that trust each
other have lower rates of crime and corruption.
They found the most trusting countries are
Canada (of course), Sweden (also not surprised),
Britain, and the USA.
Relevant (!) because trust ultimately...makes
the wheels of society turn.
Social institutions like financial markets,
public health departments, and welfare programs
require trust to operate.
The ability to trust others has also been
linked with higher rates of happiness and
health by UC Berkeley's Greater Good Science
Center.
Recently, Oxford published another study about
trust in PLOS 1, and what they found was verrrrrry
interesting.
They found that people who score higher on
measures of intelligence are more likely to
trust others, while those who score lower
on intelligence measures are more suspicious
of people.
This is after controlling for things like
income, marital status, and level of education.
What does intelligence have to do with something
like trust?
They have a couple theories.
One is that the smarties are better able to
tell someone's character.
Are they the right kind of person to let their
guard down with?
Or are they a shady brady?
A better read of someone's character may help
intelligent people to avoid those who are
more likely to betray.
Another theory is that intelligent people
are better at looking at the full context
of a situation -- so they can better evaluate
if another person has an INCENTIVE to betray
their trust.
The finding is important not just because
trust is a key player in the ever elusive
goal of peace -- but it also lends a hand
to another evolutionary theory.
The theory being that a good judge of character
is an important part of human evolution passed
on through natural selection.
In other words, reading someone's trustworthiness
has a survival advantage.
Of course, that would need some further testing.
Question for you folks: do you tend to trust
people?
Or do you find it challenging?
I mean hey, maybe you've had some experiences
that taught you otherwise.
Thanks for joining me for DNews!
I'll see you again soon with more science
updates.